Few things better explain how common
sense and morality have been so utterly
subverted than the boiling frog analogy.
So, let's talk about it. Here's how Chat
GBT defines boiling frog. Quote, "The
boiling frog is a metaphor and
cautionary tale illustrating how
individuals or societies can fail to
recognize or respond to gradual and
cumulative threats until catastrophic
consequences are unavoidable." The image
derives from a popular though
scientifically inaccurate anecdote. If a
frog is placed in boiling water, it will
immediately leap out to save itself. But
if the frog is placed in cool water that
is slowly heated, it will remain unaware
of the mounting danger until it is
boiled alive. In symbolic terms, a
boiling frog represents complacency,
habituation, and denial in the face of
incremental change. When deterioration
happens slowly, whether it involves the
erosion of civil liberties, the
normalization of corruption, the moral
decay of a culture, or even the subtle
onset of personal decline, people often
adapt to each small step rather than
resist it. Each minor shift seems
tolerable, even rationalized, until the
cumulative effect becomes disastrous.
The metaphor thus captures a
psychological and social blind spot. our
tendency to underestimate slowmoving
dangers while only noticing sudden
shocks. In essence, the boiling frog is
a metaphor for how civilizations,
organizations, or individuals slide into
ruin, not through one great leap, but
through a thousand small concessions.
Each one seemingly minor, yet taken
together become fatal. That's actually a
pretty good and accurate definition. Now
allow me to build on it by showcasing
one of those things that started off
seemingly small, but because left
unchecked has mushroomed into madness. I
speak of what is now called sexual
permissiveness, but what was once, as we
shall soon see, universally condemned as
sexual depravity and perversion. Younger
generations may not realize this, but
only a few decades ago, behaviors taken
for granted today, sex outside of
marriage, promiscuity in general, the
so-called hookup culture, were regarded
in America with the same moral revulsion
they still elicit throughout much of the
non-western world. Homosexuality,
needless to say, was considered an
ethma. In 1955, for example, the Unified
School District of Englewood in
California, mind you, partnered with the
local police to produce an educational
film warning against the quote dangers
of homosexuality
unquote. Which they described as a quote
sickness of the mind. Their words, not
mine. Take a look.
[music]
Then during lunch, Ralph showed [music]
him some pornographic pictures. Jimmy
knew he shouldn't be interested, but
well, he was curious. What Jimmy didn't
[music] know was that Ralph was sick. A
sickness that was not visible like
smallpox, but no less [music] dangerous
and contagious, a sickness of the mind.
You see, Ralph was a homosexual, [music]
a person who demands an intimate
relationship with members of their own
sex. So no matter where you meet a
stranger, be careful if they are too
friendly. If they try to win your
confidence [music] too quickly and if
they become overly personal, one never
knows when the homosexual [music] is
about. He may appear normal and it may
be too late when you discover he is
mentally ill.
>> Over a decade later, in 1966, a police
detective stood before an auditorium of
school children and delivered the same
message.
>> There may be some in this auditorium.
There may be some here today that will
be homosexual in the future. There are a
lot of kids here. There may be some
girls that will turn lesbian. We don't
know. But it's serious. Don't kid
yourselves about it. They can be
anywhere. They can be judges, lawyers.
We ought to know. We've arrested all of
them.
So, if any one of you have let yourself
become involved with an adult homosexual
or with another boy and you're doing
this on a regular basis, you better stop
quick because one out of three of you
will turn queer.
And if we catch you involved with a
homosexual, your parents are going to
know about it first. And you will be
caught. Don't think you won't be caught,
cuz this is one thing you cannot get
away with. This is one thing that if you
don't get caught by us, you'll be caught
by yourself and the rest of your life
will be a living hell.
>> Shocking. No. But here's the question.
How did we go from a time when American
authorities were openly warning children
that homosexuality was a sickness of the
mind which leads to a living hell on
earth as he just said to our present
moment when we permit children to be
indoctrinated by the very types of men
the authorities once warned against. How
did we get to a point where the sort of
sexual deviency that would have made a
1960s homosexual blush is now trumpeted
from rooftops and the entire nation is
compelled to celebrate what was once
seen as a mental disorder, if not worse.
And how did we arrive at this latest
absurdity that men and women can
transform into one another? And you you
must participate in their fiction or
else. Indeed, just a few days ago, a
group of Protestant and Jewish
denominations issued a statement
promoting and even honoring
transgenderism as holy. Okay, let me
tell you how we didn't get here. The
architects of today's sexual confusion
did not begin by forcing transgenderism
down America's throat. That would have
instantly failed because that would have
been throwing the frog in an already
boiling pot which our amphibian friend
would have instinctively jumped out of
post haste. Rather, they turned the heat
up gradually, imperceptibly. The ever
trustworthy scientists, you know, the
predecessors of those who brought you
COVID hysteria and vaccine mandates,
began by declaring that homosexuality
was absolutely normal, despite the fact
that up until 1973,
the American Psychiatric Association
itself classified it as a mental
disorder. So, homosexuality was
legitimized and presented under a whole
new set of shameless euphemisms. Being
referred to as gay, that is joyous and
merry. Don't see how that particular
lifestyle is synonymous with those happy
little words. Being represented by an
innocent looking rainbow, once the
preserve of innocent little children,
and so on and so forth. The media
complex industry naturally lent a
helping hand. All throughout the 70s,
80s, and 90s, more and more homosexuals,
all of whom were presented as
sympathetic characters, began to appear
in movies, sitcoms, and in pop culture
in general. Before long, homosexuality
became normalized in American society.
Only bigoted, unenlightened folk, which
you obviously didn't want to be counted
among, thought otherwise. After all, the
refrain went, homosexuals just wanted to
be treated with dignity and respect. And
who could oppose such a seemingly
innocuous request? But once that premise
was accepted, matters didn't end there,
did they? Put differently, once the
American frog had been acclimated, the
heat was turned up another notch. as the
next greater form of sexual confusion
was introduced. Such is the power and
efficacy of the inuring process or
what's known as creeping normality. By
the time a second milestone that is a
second greater perversion is introduced
and is creating controversy, the first
one now seen as a milder and much more
acceptable thing compared to what is now
being pushed has become an established
unquestioned fact of American society.
And so as transgenderism and now meets
some resistance, standard homosexuality
appears very moderate, morally upright
even, the frog now boiled to 200° in
transgender ideology nostalgically earns
for the good old days when the water was
only 150°, forgetting that even that was
much too hot, 70° or so being ideal and
healthy. And so we come to the current
situation where conservatives,
Republicans, and even Christians are
falling over themselves to endorse Pete
Butterag style homosexuality.
You know, two normal guys marrying and
adopting children. Whereas that too was
once and as seen a sickness of the mind.
The American frog, long boiled into
numbness, is grateful for 50° less heat.
Incidentally, this is why President
Donald Trump's executive order affirming
that there are only two sexes is for me
less a triumph and much more of an
embarrassment. What kind of nation
requires its commanderin-chief to expend
political capital to reaffirm what every
toddler instinctively knows and what
science and nature have always
confirmed. However, because we've been
at such a high boil for many years,
passing such an executive order felt and
was treated like a great victory because
it was a lessening of the infernal boil.
And so, we're thankful for it. In
reality, we should be expecting and
demanding much more than that. Before
closing, and if this little presentation
struck you as homophobic or offensive,
let me ask you something. As you've
seen, the classification of
homosexuality as a mental disorder
wasn't my invention. It reflected what
American society, including its
scientific establishment, believed and
what most of the non-western world still
believes. So, what changed? Did
groundbreaking new evidence emerge
proving that earlier Americans, indeed,
the whole world, had been wrong all
along? Or were you, like our proverbial
boiling frog, gradually cooked, that is,
methodically desensitized by ceaseless,
ubiquitous lies, to the point that you
can no longer separate fact from
fiction?
>> Stick a fork in me, Jerry.
I'm done.